Hey Thoughty2 here. The room is dark, the
duvet is wrapped warm around you, you’ve
finally put your damn phone down and you wonder
“why am I not asleep yet?”
Sometimes, no matter how much you want to,
you simply cannot find the off button. You’ve
tried everything; counting sheep, breathing
exercises, listening to whale songs, you’ve
even tried counting whales and listening to
sheep songs but nothing is working. Why does
this happen? If mother nature decided that
we needed to spend a third of the day recharging,
then why did she make it so bloody difficult
to do it.
We all know how frustrating it can be so let’s
try to understand what’s preventing you
from dosing off and how you can help it along
a little.
First things first; what is the difference
between being awake and being asleep? You
close your eyes, you lie still, you breathe
deeply, you can even try dribbling a little,
but something special has to happen for you
to make the mysterious switch to the other
side.
There are 5 stages of sleep. In the first,
you move from an Alpha state, basically daydreaming,
into a Theta state, where your brain locks
down your muscles and prepares to move into
deeper sleep. You could say that you’re
technically asleep in Theta, but very lightly.
It’s at this stage where the Hypnic Jerk
can occur, that moment when you suddenly twitch
awake as if you’re falling. We think it’s
likely to be caused by your brain still being
conscious when sleep paralysis sets in. It
could have been an evolutionary benefit so
that our old primate ancestors didn’t fall
out the tree when they had a little nap on
a branch. But, given that, in the US alone,
1.8 million people visit the emergency room
every year because they fell out of bed, evolution
has quite a long way to go.
In stage two, your brain sends out waves called
sleep spindles that we think are used as a
sort of thought-jammer to keep you calm and
stop you thinking about the washing up or
that spreadsheet or where you hid the bodies.
Stage 3 is the transition from light sleep
to deep sleep and stage 4 is when you get
a rush of delta waves and you are deepest
asleep. Stage 4 last about 30 minutes and
is the best time to draw on someone’s face.
Finally, you get stage 5, when REM occurs
and this is when your body repairs itself,
jots down memories permanently and makes you
feel rested.
But the big question for today is; what kicks
off this whole process? What happens to lead
you to the Theta state in stage one, where
it all begins?
So there are two main factors that control
sleepiness. One is sleep pressure, something
that increases the longer you’ve been awake,
and is created by the release of. The level
rises while you’re awake and then you break
it down when you sleep. The next factor is
the light. We may now have 24hr supermarkets
and skype calls at 3am but we’re not designed
for this. We’re supposed to get up at sunrise
and sleep at sunset, like the Tellytubbies.
This is done through melatonin which is released
when it’s dark, helping you to feel sleepy.
As the sun rises, your body releases cortisol
which gets you up and ready for another day
in your repetitive and pointless existence.
Okay, so what happens to interrupt this complicated
process? One day you’re snoring like a pig
in a blanket and then bam! you’re up at
4am watching youtube for the fifth night in
a row and, although this video is both entertaining
and educational, you’re welcome by the way,
you’d probably rather be dreaming of chocolate
dinosaur land and riding a Tyrannosaurus Twix,
and not waking up feeling like you’ve been
in a cage fight.
Stress is probably the main cause of “why
can’t I f’in sleep”, because stress
just throws all of your systems out of whack;
hormone levels go all over the place, heart
rhythms change, it’s a mess. So you need
to manage this through tackling the cause
of your stress. Not saying that’s easy,
but there’s plenty of professional support
out there. Sorry I can’t help you on that
front.
Then there’s drugs; both illegal and legal.
Caffeine, for example, works by attaching
to the adenosine receptors, and speeding up
nerve cell activity, where adenosine would
slow it down. So no tea before bedtime, unless
it’s one of those herbal monstrosities.
If you want to call some salad in hot water
“tea”, that’s your prerogative, I’ll
be over here with my comforting beige brew.
When insomnia strikes, some people turn to
alcohol or marijuana but neither is really
a great option. Both can help you to get to
the early sleep stages fairly quickly but
they reduce the amount of time in stage 5,
REM sleep, so you won’t wake up feeling
refreshed, and your room will smell of fosters
and domino’s pizza.
When it comes to melatonin, the biggest enemy
is your phone screen. It’s thought that
the biggest obstacle to most people falling
asleep today is technology. The light from
a smartphone or a laptop is enough to trick
your brain into thinking it’s still daylight
so you won’t produce the necessary melatonin.
It can increase the time it takes you to fall
asleep by over an hour. It’s important to
give yourself a good 30 minutes before bed
with no screens. You should try that new app,
where people take all of the subtitles from
famous movies and print them out on sheets
of paper, except more articulately written.
There’s a lot of misinformation out there
about sleep, partly because there is so much
we don’t understand. So let’s try to tackle
a few of the more common myths.
Firstly, the obvious one; counting sheep.
It’s thought that this whole concept is
derived from actual shepherds. They would
worry about their flocks going missing at
night so, to make sure all was well, they
would go out and count up the little land
clouds. For you and me though, with our worries
being decidedly non-ovine, counting sheep
is completely unhelpful as it stimulates the
active parts of your brain. You’re much
better off picturing a relaxing scene, like
a beach or a waterfall. And sure, that can
include sheep if you like, just make sure
nobody else is in attendance.
Exercise is important to keep you healthy
and a good active day will help you nod off.
But if you’re restless, doing some sit ups
is only going to make things worse since you
will increase adrenaline and, more importantly,
raise your core temperature. Heat equilibrium
is important for sleep and you should be aiming
to keep your extremities warm, like with socks,
but your core cool, which is easy if you have
a frosty heart.
And finally, we’re often told that you can
train yourself to need less sleep. Well, you
can’t. You can learn to put up with it and
maybe control your mood a bit better but the
fact is, we each have a typical sleep requirement,
which differs from person to person, often
7-8 hours, and with any less than that, we
won’t be running at our optimum; concentration
will drop, your temper will be shorter and
you’ll find Janice in human resources that
extra bit annoying. Sure, she’s irritating
on a good day but without a good sleep, she’s
like listening to Paris Hilton reading 50
Shades of Grey over a severely bad Skype connection.
But no matter how much sleep you manage to
get each night the best way to wake up feeling
refreshed is to avoid waking up during deep-sleep.
Doing so will make you feel groggy and sleepy
for hours afterwards; wake up during light-sleep
and you’ll feel awake and refreshed. But
it’s not down to luck, you can actually
plan to wake up during light-sleep, every
morning. It takes the brain 90 minutes to
go through one full sleep cycle. So try to
always set your alarm in 90-minute intervals,
giving you the best chance of waking up during
light-sleep. So you could set your alarm for
6 hours after you go to bed, or 7 and ½ hours
or 9 hours, all are divisible by 90 minutes.
Just make sure you factor in the average of
14 minutes it takes for a person to fall asleep.
So, I hope this has helped some of the insomniacs
out there; although I’m not sure it was
too smart of me to tell my entire audience
to stop staring at screens. No staring after
midnight, deal? And for those of you who do
sleep like a baby, I hope you have someone
to change you in the middle of the night,
because you really should have grown out of
that by now. Thanks for the view, subscribe
for more Thoughty2.